va beh stavolta attraversato la porta
devi essere buono sonorità e starò bene
fa il mio nome
benvenuti sua ninja tories ogni volta
che facciamo in video di notte alle 3 di
notte
dobbiamo fare la rubrica rita storia di
cinque oggi a grandissima richiesta
giocherò alloro molto inquietanti 1 ere
che eri tice aiuto avete consigliato di
giocare a questo gioco
in pratica c'è una maestra non fosse una
maestra cattiva killer è arrivato anche
lui vuole giocare
il killer delle crocchette burley volete
imprese il protagonista al centro
dell'attenzione la berlina youtuber lio
ha deciso di coprire vitale perché
dovete sapere che merlino
innamoratissimo e innamoratissimo
digitale nessuno può guardarlo al di voi
può guardare trova quindi il primo gioco
ascheri tiziano in cui c'è una maestra
inquietante noi a vento non abbiamo mai
giocato quindi non ho idea di come si sa
è il secondo gioco e granny versione
natalizia granny babbo natale tonica più
il terzo gioco qui giocheremo un altro
gioco che ci chiedete sempre e devil
quindi siete pronti prendete i pop corn
mettetevi comodi iniziamo subito via
siamo pronti perché allora scegliamo
sono anche scelgo la femmina fantasy
licata ritrova la trappola per topi e
mettila tavolo quindi dobbiamo fare
degli scherzetti e cosa la maestra
[Musica]
auction numero di losine oggi apriamo ha
preso il giornale del tradate altro caso
il mio piano è bello che posso vederla
nel radar almeno riuscito a capire dove
più o meno invece cremino mi capissi vai
vai ancora li sta lottando
penso che mi vedrò da quando vai vai vai
scappa scappa scappa aperto nei primi 30
secondi
cominciamo allora ok mi ha fatto
riniziare da qua a lei è sopra quindi mi
diceva di mettere la trappola del mouse
topo sul tavo
a prima no questi fare devi selezionare
perché non c'era la trappola per topi
forse devo trovarla da prendere già
trovato al tiro di una forte aiuto dove
sta andando di relativa che mi sta bene
ha fatto a tirare la porta in faccia ma
l'iniziale o ancora la torta ma non mi
serve lasciamo pronto io dove la
trappola lasciava portavoce partner o
forse fuori se il giardino vogliono
acquistare la tratta con una provato ma
non da quello e raccogli sete si sta
avvicinando con questo testo non lo puoi
buttare
che cosa è presso la spazzatura e se sì
prendiamolo magari ci può essere una è
una vita che ti ha dato più
elettricità e dobbiamo trovare questa
trappola per topi per farle lo fa perché
una finestra figure casa
cioè io ti faccio vedere come si gioca
ma come se la cava vitale perché sta
guardando in alto
minuta e molto difficile questo gioco
fatti sapere nei commenti se voi avete
mai giocato
allora io aspetterei un attimino qui
finché lei non si allontana allora sta
andando verso la cucina se non sbaglio
[Musica]
allora dobbiamo trovare innanzitutto la
trappola per topi nostri stili allora lì
c'è lei sta vicino ad un dong minuto
sopra evitare che dice come i numeri le
pen si gioca è poi stato preso subito
dentro allora dove sta
ok al piano di sopra così abbiamo un po
di tempo per trovare questo trappola per
topi che cos'è questa cosa che sono ogni
volta che paura
andiamo 6 sta qui la trappola castori
sotto il lavandino ci sarà la trasferta
di no questo che poteva un frigo una
chiave cerchiamo credito nave ma non si
serve ed è una breve magari servirà dopo
una stella
beh quello è una scatolina e una caduta
dei primi veri al tiro in testa quando
una torta ma c'è portata per tutto qui
questo che cos'è un martello
prendiamolo e fuori il giardino lei ma
perfetto così noi possiamo andare avanti
a cercare qui in casa dopo perché non
posso andare avanti qui potrebbe stare
qui
lei è ancora fuori quindi possiamo
continuare a girare no se non c'è
eccola è viva ok prendi lavorativi
mettere sul tavolo facevo faccio
arrivare al tavolo ma stai stato e
tappeto mi tira
ok ora devi devi dice di coprirla con il
pezzo di giornale
ok ora parla k k
vediamo se cassiera nel nostro
scherzetto ha chiesto scappato ha fatto
male poverina la mano rossissima
poverina incavo l'estate cattivissima
con noi sono il miglior chef del mondo e
fotografia fatto il risotto io sono
stato di cereali green l'ottimo vabbè
allora bisogna essere l'unica che ci ha
visto il mondo per faber latte che
generale quindi questa missione e
rovinare la colazione alla maestra
attento giorno trappola non l'avevo
visto mai un me l'hai detto a prenderla
ok ok lei si è seduta su un divano non è
questo non ho quindi dobbiamo trovare la
cucina da cucina sarà quella infondono
si unì rimettiamolo trappola attenzione
caesar li metti stare vincere allora che
stia venendo qui però la miss teacher
sbrigati metti stare iniziare a marrubiu
pagina ok metti la mia verità
ok ora devi scappare
salta salta salta salta salta salta
anche quel giardino coppola ha salvato
pure lei mi faccio campare la donna
dalle scale dove sono saltato misano si
potrà essere qui sotterraneo dove luce i
tacchi che a sinistra stessa
spero che tale sia già nei cereali e non
ti credo mi ha messo a sedere di mancano
[Musica]
famiglia mi ha detto verdi ei ora
passiamo a gremi modalità babbo natale
spaventò io ho già scelto modalità
facile non sono uno che non è così
un trattore e tutto per decorare le
pareti di natale che mai vicino alla
casa di graining ho fatto vedere questo
adesso arriva arriva
mi chiedo se lo studente si perché di
solito arriva subito ma questa è la
modalità facile penso che sia più facile
[Applauso]
sta arrivando gialloverde siccome si
chiude strano ma c'è solo la mano è
ancora 5 età nostre ricchezze sono una
mano attraverso la porta ha lavorato
attraversato la porta
prendiamoci coraggio che andiamo
ma perché beh non mi ha visto che strano
labbra che dicevo ma mi sembrava pò
natale non è vedere mi sta dando molto
strano
scappa scappa da una mano lei vestita da
babbo natale l'ho vista
modera che cavolo di 23 spongebob
ma questo di spam bot prendi oro andiamo
giornale di arresti che è successo qua
perché è tutto rosa un po strano queste
zone c'è i colori un po strani il più
essere natalizia per ograve spongebob
garage fa più paura di grandi c'è
qualcosa che non va in questo gioco
ok allora abbiamo scoperto che
quell'altro gioco di grendi babbo natale
in realtà era tipo click day perché in
realtà granny babbo natale azioni libro
alla fine risponde che fate non c'era
proprio g natale o babbo natale cattivo
quindi ne abbiamo trovato un altro
questo il quadro erbe esserci cremina
tale o babbo natale più carino e allegro
e data litio tranne che c'è un babbo
natale malefico che vuole colpirti con
la madre o vetere in bagno innanzitutto
visto che è vicino qualche bello sbaglia
e pulitissimo e bellissimo
sembra proprio di pezza di un pezzo del
quadro non diamo giu
andiamo al garage questo almeno è
davvero babbo natale malefico questo
proviamo a scendere vogliamo scendere
cinema che in tutto ciò c'è di bari
bando
ok mettiamo su mary mary di natale il
pezzo di babbo natale li andiamo a
vedere giù ad un pochino meglio rispetto
a quello di prima
mamma mentre paura questo ragazzo qui
che ci abbiamo il libro il libro lo
possiamo mettere al piano di sopra che
c'entra halloween vediamo vediamo saremo
solo speriamo che non ci si era subito
che ha visto
mamma mia è bruttissima scappiamo qua
dietro sappiamo che dietro lo vede
speriamo che non sia arrivato da qui qui
c'è un pezzo difficile
vediamo dato il milan i nodi che
inquietante quell'occhio si gioca lì
anche eccolo lì dietro capisca questa ma
andiamo di qua in cucina allora qui
c'era la finestra possiamo saltare dalla
finestra diavolo di filo che fa suonare
niente non mi pesano non mi ha preso non
mi prendo la mia preso non mi presto
possibile che non ti ha preso
perché tanta corri corri casi vediamo
vediamo mai bastare una stia di nuovo
qui a dire che le sta bene le auschwitz
babbo natale guardandoli da stola
aspettando che ci avviciniamo secondo me
fa provo a fare rumore che ti amo se
viene da questa parte a qui c'è un pezzo
di quadro è rimasta ferma dei gremi
babbo natale 6 bloccarli sulla porta non
diamo se faccio vedere il libro ma anche
no
ma ai capelli adesso il minuto perché
non mi fa sapere quarto ai capelli
castani capelli lunghi capelli rasta che
la donna da babbo natale lunga ma perché
non reagisce sta ferma lì c'è qualcosa
di strano che poi ha dovuto disporre
serve bene in faccia per rivedere la
barba è che brutta ma non si è accorta
che avesse avuto a che è arrivato il
momento adesso di giocare a the film
nine super curioso perché mi dite sempre
che quello più inquietante di tutti in
ora complimenti il tuo bambino è stato
selezionato per partecipare
gratuitamente al nuovo campeggio estivo
organizzato da questa scuola imparerà ad
essere una brava persona attraverso un
nuovo metodo didattico con la massima
cura e attenzione trascorrere un'estate
indimenticabile
mi sembra una trappola ok allora quale
immagina che sia la macchina che mi sta
portando da haven nun maltempo fatto
molto bene ma dall'inizio
un po come mister nizza diciamo ricordo
mister mette eccola ma perché che non
cominciata bene giorno 1 quindi anche
qua abbiamo i giorni che devi essere
buono sono unità e starò bene fa il mio
nome
penso che dovrei guardarmi intorno prima
di andare avanti ok qua ra qua ci sono
del dei graffi box abbiamo fatto rumore
prova inquietante questa sarebbe la mia
stanza molto guarda c'è un dialogo ha
disegnato che succede forse potrei aver
bisogno di rannicchiarsi come faccio a
rai macchiarmi ok un cassetto e guarda
anche se tu niente non c'è niente devo
lasciare questa scuola si immaginavo che
dove si esce
eccolo ecco ok proviamo uscire wow
questo è il fatto benissimo questo gioco
c'era una mano blu là sopra disegnato
hai visto qui ma non altro porto che
vediamo se devo andare
o attenta tenta standista di ristampare
deve scappare di scappare questa
striscia di sangue e paura aiuto che ora
prova vita del giorno 2
che cos'è quella una bomba no credo sia
un orologio sembra una bomba non c'e
scritto chiuso
vediamo vediamo lasciamo da qui che
sicuramente non c'è niente ok allora
piano di ammortamento chiuso la porta
l'ha fatta lui non ha fatto niente
l'ultimo giorno quindi abbiamo solo
solissimo orche mannaggia
ci provo ce la faremo
forse devi seguire la scelta di ci
proviamo
era entrata intento che non arrivi che
cos'è questa volta le col fuoco
oddio inquietante
uscita ci vuole
sembra che la corrente non raggiunga a
questo interessante che ho paura che era
scappata ma non mi dicano dove erano
interessate ok più si è bloccato
addizione catino bonato
enorme questa scuola centro dei passi
siete dei passi sono ritornato qui
dietro avevate ragione questo fa davvero
paura
chiudi gremio più realistico gli ha
lasciato un mi piace se volete il
continuo in cui continuiamo a giocare a
devil nun e scriveteci magari qualche
consiglio scriveteci quale secondo voi
di questi sono i giochi quello che vi ha
fatto più povero quello che viviamo
divertito di più e ora vi lasciamo 4
castellini e tu puoi cliccare per vedere
i nostri altri video e kakà su quella
che preferita è buona ciao
anche il cuore divertente
[Musica]
queste materie non ci mancano mai